a little bit short like maybe 10 minutes
open problem session related to the last
couple of lectures so I mean I'll
mention a couple of problems and then
open it up for anybody else who has
comments or ideas about problems so okay
so the most obvious of a problem I mean
it's been a theme in the last three
lectures including Yan's lecture is that
all these proofs prove that certain
objects exist but we don't know how we
don't have algorithms for finding them
so we have a bunch of algorithmic
questions so one is is there an
algorithm for Weavers problem this
problem of given a set of vectors can
you partition it into two subsets the
three subsets the norm is much less
covariance matrix I mean this has some
several interesting combinatorial
problems with sub cases which I didn't
talk about but I mean part of the reason
people were interested in this
conjecture is that if you apply it to
the passions of graphs you get fairly
interesting statements about graphs so
here so here's an easier problem this is
something that's called a spectral eight
entry
so spectrally a thin tree is a spanning
tree of a graph
and let's suppose the well are actually
yeah so and let's suppose the graph G
has M edges
especially if the entry is a tree which
approximates the graph in a particular
sense this is is that if you look at the
laplacian of the graph and you look at
its quadratic form then this is
approximated by the passion of the tree
in the following sense
certainly the laplacian of the tree
certain we had most of a portion of the
graph because it's the tree is the sub
graph of the graph and the laplacian of
the tree is also it has one eigenvalue
equal to 0 because it's a passion but
it's connected so it has otherwise
nonzero eigenvalues especially its entry
is a tree with the property that the
tree not only is it smaller than the
graph it's smaller than the graph in
about the appropriate ratio so the tree
has n minus 1 edges a graph has images
especially if m tree is a tree such that
the portion of the tree is at most some
constant times n over m times of a
portion of the graph so you want to
think of this as you know a tree which
is proportionally smaller than the graph
M is the number of edges in the graph
and is the number n is the number of
vertices n minus 1 this is the ratio of
the number of edges in the tree to the
number of edges in the graph and this is
some constant so why are people
interested in the statement well in
particular wants one thing this implies
is that if you look at any cut so if you
look at any if you look at the boundary
of any set in the tree if you look at
the number of edges leaving leaving this
set this is at most again see n over m
times the boundary of the same set in
the graph so this implies statement
about all cuts by plugging in 2 0 1
vectors in this quadratic form ok so not
all graphs have have have these
speculation trees but one implication of
Weavers conjecture one thing that it
implies is that every graph a spectrally
may be Oh
every graph has the spectrally it has a
tree with the laplacian of the tree
bounded by r times the laplacian of the
graph where r is the maximum effective
resistance of an edge in there so it's I
mean it's so it's quite natural to see
why something like effective resistance
would show up because you know the
canonical graph which doesn't have a
thin tree is this graph right so this is
a graph what any tree is going to
completely saturate this cut it's not
gonna shrink that cut by a factor of n
over m and that edge has effective
resistance 1 so this is one way of
articulating you know saying that a
graph doesn't have these kind of edges
and so we know that we know this is true
ok this is a simple consequence of
Weaver's conjecture and so so maybe a
simpler question of combinatorial
question is can you get an algorithm for
respect release in trees
there's also something called distaff
entry a combinatorially sentry and i
mean you know one reason this is
relevant so I'll just make a remark is
that a combinatorial sentry and that
just means this inequality holds only
for zero one vectors only four cuts is
known to exist with instead of the
maximum effective resistance you have R
equal to some poly log log n divided by
the edge connectivity
this is due to Inari and a vase quran
this has implications for the asymmetric
traveling salesman problem this is why
they were interested in this and again
this does not have a constructive proof
so we have all these nice combinatorial
statements about graphs we know that
these trees exist but we have no idea
how to find them maybe this is easier
than solving we respond 1/3 perhaps
easier algorithmic problem is or
something that's suggested by what
happens for the matching polynomial is
is there an algorithm for approximating
the roots of mix characteristic
polynomials if you could do this
sufficiently well then you would get a
solution of Weavers problem because all
these interlacing techniques all you
need to do is approximate roots of mix
characteristic polynomials very well so
this is another sort of more analytic
question that's right yeah I'm sorry
largest root and if you have some
question here is do the moments of the
roots count anything
this is very speculative because it's
inspired by the fact that for the
matching polynomial get three like walks
but the fact that they can't feel like
tree like walks right
it doesn't help much algorithmically but
it yet again provides maybe in a line of
attack right if it counts something
maybe you can count it using Markov
chain so far we don't so far we don't
know how to country like walks either so
maybe have easiest question is tell tree
like walks tree like walks up to 1 plus
epsilon accuracy in time polynomial in N
and 1 over Epsilon
so right now we have this in time
exponential and whatever epsilon if you
could count tree like walks maybe that's
a stepping stone to eventually doing
this which would imply all this other
stuff what could be in here counting
through like walks guys oh this yeah we
have some I mean for the graphs you have
some specific victories this would be I
mean it doesn't have to do anything to
this to like what we don't know which
one it is there a meaning self these
characteristic polynomials when the
vector so from the graph yeah okay is
not the same
okay you're saying when the vectors come
from you're saying in these applications
the vectors come from a graph which is
not actually the same as what you do for
the matching yeah so so you you know you
could consider various sub cases right
so sub cases of this are I haven't told
you what the reduction to these century
problems is but you get a special class
of matrices when you do that later to
the questions maybe you can do it for
that sub case yeah so these are some of
the algorithmic problems and I guess
maybe I'll just leave some time for
people to say their own problems
otherwise I can say more but
[Applause]
matrixyl of both so there are all things
when this is one thing okay yeah yeah
that's a good question so yeah what
[ __ ] is saying is there's an
intermediate regime which is Weaver's
problem is easy for Delta equals one
over log n I mean just by picking random
signs can you even solve it or just any
Delta that's bigger than in that example
you get walking over walking in the
balls and Ben's example you get walking
over logo again I don't think matrix
turnoff gives you login oh okay fine
okay fine
so let's make this log log n so okay
yeah there's a result of Harvey and
offer yes log log log n over log n right
so I mean okay there's this as you can
see that there you know there's this
hardest problem and there are various
sub cases that are interesting and
possibly easier so maybe it's worth
attacking one of the combinatorial
formulations first
[Music]
okay one other obvious open problem left
open from the last three lectures is can
you construct non bipartite Ramanujan
graph so in these lectures we explained
how to construct graphs whose second
eigenvalue is bounded by two squared D
minus 1 that didn't actually use
anything about non bipartite miss but if
a graph is a bipartite graph or graph is
bipartite its eigenvalues are symmetric
about 0 so if for free if the graph is
bipartite you get that lambda n minus 1
is at least minus 2 squared t minus 1
which is the definition of one bipartite
Robin is in graph but there's this weird
gap which is we know how to prove all
this stuff using this trick controlling
just the largest fruit because remember
interlacing only allows you to control
one root at a time we know how to use
this sort of you know cheap trick to
like turn just say oh well you get one
side you get the other side for free
because it's my part I it we we actually
don't have any techniques for
controlling two roots at a time
so the question of can you construct
graphs for which all the non-trivial
eigenvalues are bounded in absolute
value by 2 root 3 minus 1 it's still
open only known for prime powers plus 1
so for revolution graphs the the ball
ski Phillips on a construction so Katie
graph
okay like so we have using this method
to give something that has more
symmetric oh yeah that's that's a great
question so maybe I'll write it over
here so so one more question is and you
get kilograms
using well using whatever method but
perhaps using interlacing families right
so Liu Bachchan Phillips our neck prove
certain kailia graphs are robbers and
graphs this has very good computational
properties kala graphs are strongly
explicit that means that for any vertex
you can figure out what its neighbors
are in poly log so that's still open can
you get you know can you get strongly
explicit expander' graphs for all
degrees and maybe in all sizes we don't
know so you know right now the again
these techniques are highly non
constructive we don't know almost
anything about the graphs that they
produce so I have a question for so
these are for regular graphs regular
class by looking at the universal cover
you can also go find some yes yeah so
that's a good question so everything I
said works for the hypothesis so for any
graph so the setting is you take any
graph you look at its Universal cover it
has some spectral radius you can prove
that the roots of the matching
polynomial bounded by that spectral
radius so by what I discussed yesterday
that implies that every graph has a
cover whose roots new eigen values are
bound by the spectral radius is
universal so irregularity is not a
problem
okay well I guess I'll just end here
[Music]
[Applause]